I got a bottle of the mosa seeds to expel parasites.
It says to take two pills a day.
So the mosa is a product that we use a lot with our lime patients over the years.
It's nice because it kills directly.
It doesn't work to stimulate an immune response, which is not good.
If you're in base three live and you have a bottle of immune condition type line.
So that's good.
But my probiotics say to take on an empty stomach just as this does.
Does taking the seeds ruined the effects of the probiotics plus the supplements I take the rest of the day by pulling them all in the body as well.
So I think is I would just try to leave it like 15 minutes away from each other and they may never even see each other in the back.
I don't think the mosa is going to damage your gut flora at all.
I've never heard of that happening.
We've used it very it's a very safe product and I don't think it's going to affect your probiotics.